Namo dasa bhagavato arahato sambha sambodasa Namo dasa bhagavato arahato sambha sambodasa Namo dasa bhagavato arahato
So greetings to all you revelers in full moon delights.
So this is some of these
months lend themselves to certain subjects so obviously this one is about love so i re-read i've read it about five times over the years eric from's classic the art of loving and some of you might know definitely worth the read anyway and uh i'm gonna he starts off but i'm gonna turn it into a sort of question like when we do something
or say something or think something out of love do we do it in order to love in order to develop our love or do we do it to be loved that's a cheeky one that right so then uh he talks about uh why uh we need this love and he of course it's a psychoanalysis thing and um when we're born you know for those first few months or so there's no separation between us and our mothers
And so that's really a halcyon pierce, a heavenly state to be in.
And then, of course, the separation starts, which is needed for the child to become a little independent being.
But that separation is a sense of loss.
And according to psychoanalysis, that's what produces our loneliness in life, because we want to get back to that wonderful place we were when we were babies.
From the Buddha's point of view, from the Dharma's point of view rather, of course it's more to do with the essential relationship that we make with this psychophysical organism that we call the self.
And the self knows that it is
unstable, it comes to know that it's not secure.
So the fundamental position from a dharma point of view is this feeling of unsafety.
And because of that, we start collecting things.
And that's the first thing that the Buddha talks about.
It's translated as greed, but it's much better to see it as acquisitiveness.
So we acquire things, and there are four major areas where we do that, of course.
Rich, you know, I want to be rich like loads of money, like Scrooge.
And the more I have, the safer I feel.
You know, if I've got a million pound in the bank, I feel really safe.
And then there's power.
Control, control over our lives, control over people makes us feel safe.
We're in charge.
That's also can be a real pain.
And then there's pleasure, of course, you know, seeking just people who just want one experience after the other.
You know, been there, got the T-shirt, all that sort of stuff.
Foodies, you know, who live for the next exciting diet or menu rather.
And then finally, there's those who seek to be appreciated, seek to be praised.
And that's usually we're seeking some sort of fame.
OK.
So here we're dealing with fame or the desire to be loved.
Yeah.
Now, that would be, of course, also a cause of loneliness.
The fact that when we feel lonely, then we have these little words going on in our heads about how useless we are and horrible.
And what we do, we tend to reinforce that by forming friendships, by, shall we say, padding out our friendships by making sure that they are stable friendships.
We don't want to lose them because then we'd feel really lonely.
But that unfortunately is a bad strategy because what it does is it makes us dependent on them.
and uh and and what it means is that when we have our self-worth or our self-esteem is dependent on what other people think about us or what they say about us how they treat us and therefore is you know sometimes you feel pretty rotten if you do that and of course uh people whom you love disappear they either leave you or they get fed up with you and some of them die so so nothing
Nothing is to be taken for granted.
So there's always that little sense of anxiety of loss.
Anything you become attached to is going to create some anxiety of loss.
And the other thing we do, of course, is to seek distraction.
And I'll come to that in a minute.
So the best strategy is actually to love, to come from the position of love.
So when you come from a position of love, you immediately fill yourself with good feelings, good feelings about yourself.
And that sense of self-worth, self-esteem comes naturally when we behave from a position of love and all the other positions, social virtues of compassion, joy, etc.
so um how do we you know how do we purify our love first of all is to recognize that this this thing about the self and it's feeling lonely and it's needed and its neediness that has to be recognized so that when we are doing something we've got to see these little background voices
In the Buddhist teachings, they're known as latent tendencies, the anusaya, the latent tendencies.
So they're always there, ready to be fired.
And in psychology, they'd call it subconscious motivations.
So that's where we get the idea of Freudian slips.
See, something's happening in the back of the mind, we're not recognizing it, and it comes out in a slip that makes us feel embarrassed.
So when we're about to do something or say something or even think something, you've always got to be aware of this little other dialogue that's going on.
So it might be, for instance, well, I'm going to do your garden and I hope the background little voice is saying, and you'll come and do mine when I need it.
Or, I know you'll really love me after this.
You'll really appreciate my friendship.
So there's always these little things going on in the background.
And it's a case really of making those conscious.
Now, as soon as they become conscious, they lose power over you.
So if you remember, after the Buddha was fully liberated, there were seven years it said that Mara chased him with his three daughters.
So sensual desire, sexual desire.
And if you don't know the third one, I'll leave you to guess it.
And after seven years, he sort of began to go away, you see.
And he sort of said, what's happening?
He said, well, the Buddha sees me.
He sees me.
He says, well, give us a bit more time.
He says, no, he says, after seven years, I'm not going to get through.
I'm not going to get through to the Buddha.
So as soon as we see these little conversations coming from the self, the neediness of the self, the wanting to be loved, they don't have power over us.
and we then re-establish our commitment to doing something from the heart of love and that's how you begin that's how we begin to purify our hearts now the purification of the heart demands a lessening of the self so therefore itself is a path of love is the path of liberation rather excuse me the path of purification is itself a path of liberation
Normally, of course, we put the accent on insight, on seeing things, which is absolutely necessary as well.
But with the path of love, this is the process.
You're constantly purifying your intentions, coming from the heart.
And it's funny, there was...
There's always an effort in philosophy to give you reasons.
There's not time to go into the way that philosophers think about ethical behaviour, love, compassion and joy and all that.
They try to give us rational reasons.
But the great Scottish philosopher Hume, and I've heard him called the philosopher's philosopher, says that whenever he looked into an act of goodwill, always he didn't find a reason at the bottom of it.
What he found was a sentiment, and that's his word for something that arises out of the heart.
and confucius said that the ground of a harmonious society was benevolence and concern love and compassion so everything everything around love always begins in the heart now the only problem is that it's not it's not always a feeling you don't have to feel loving in order to act from a position of goodwill so for instance
A surgeon who's operating, I doubt if they feel some great big gushing love towards their patient.
I mean, their attention is on what they're doing.
They should be equanimous, calm, cool, right?
So again, when we say the heart, we're really talking about attitude.
We're not talking about feeling.
The feeling is sometimes there and it sometimes isn't.
That's important.
Okay, so that gives us some idea as to how to make ourselves, how to make our acts of love, the way we speak and the way we think, coming from the heart of love, more and more pure.
But let's just say just a word about loneliness.
Now, when we feel lonely,
um it's a bit it's a bit of a downer for the self because what you know the the language is something like you know nobody loves me who could love me i mean i'm horrible you know and all that and all that sort of really really upsetting uh talk so we try to escape that as soon as you feel lonely as soon as it actually just drips into consciousness
Off we go, we turn on the TV, get onto social media, open a new packet of biscuits, anything but feel the loneliness.
And that's of course why we don't like to tell people we feel lonely, because what we're saying to them is that we're not loved, we're not appreciated.
so it's a difficult one for us now if uh by trying to escape it of course it still remains there as one of these anusaya as one of these latent tendencies and what it's going to do is going to make you overact your love to other people so that you can prove that you are appreciated
You're going to be overly joyous at people's success just so they know that you are joyous and that you are to be praised because of that and that appreciated and loved.
So you've got to tackle the loneliness in its rawness.
And this is what vipassana teaches us.
So we go into the mental state, the feel of it.
And you have to have the patience, you have to be open to it.
And it helps to have a sense of care towards it, a sense of wanting to...
wanting to heal the heart of it and that gives you a right attitude towards the feeling of loneliness but you still have to go in there you have to sink into it and feel the raw feelings and of course what you're doing is you're opening up to your heart the heart wants to speak to you it speaks in feelings in mental states
And in so doing, what you're doing is we're letting off that steam.
We're allowing that turbulence to manifest as turbulence, as energy.
And therefore, it's exhausting itself, just like anything else.
If you go for a run, at the end of it, you feel exhausted.
So if you give the heart a run, it'll feel exhausted.
And now the really important thing is, if you can, see this is a really important thing, if you can to stay to the very last sensation caused by that loneliness, right?
Because if you stay there, you might see the transformation.
And that energy is never lost.
It always transforms towards its opposite.
And what you may experience is a sense of wonderful relief and peacefulness.
But also, to your great surprise, it might burst out into this universal love for all beings.
It's quite remarkable what will happen if you stay to the end.
You don't have to stay to the end for this technique to allow the heart to purify itself.
But if you do, it gives you real confidence because now you know
that all these negative mental states are always moving towards the opposites.
No energy is lost.
And of course, that doesn't mean to say that when they are their opposites, when you do feel love, these mental states can be developed indefinitely.
So in other words, after this year of real commitment, you should be constantly sailing in a piece of joyous love.
No doubt about it.
Unfortunately, this universal love that we're trying to get to, this sort of love which is above
any attached any love to do with attachments uh is is something we have to develop all these other loves if you think about it come naturally you know i mean there's a natural loving of parents towards their children you don't you don't um you don't organize yourself you don't sort of set yourself up to fall in love you just fall in love you know you meet somebody
and you like them and before you know it you fall in love or you've developed a friendship because of that sort of connection between two hearts.
All these types of love are just part of our natural human nature but to lift it into this universal love, this meta, takes effort.
You've got to lift yourself out of that stuff and really make an effort to
open up your heart to all beings in all directions so that's really the final thing so so uh the question then is uh to love or to be loved right am i shakespeare and hamlet that's the question to love or to be loved in terms of our daily activity in the in terms of our spiritual practice and if we keep an eye on these anusaya these latent tendencies
we'll get a hang of it, you see.
It means that you've got to have a slightly more spacious awareness, an awareness which is not only about what's out there, but a constant sort of inner awareness, like you know all the time how you're feeling.
It's just there in the sort of background.
And when something moves, an irritation or something like that, you become aware of it.
And because you're aware of it, it no longer has control over you.
And you can just either park it so you're not pushing it away with fear or with aversion.
So those are suppressive measures.
You're just putting it to the side and reestablishing your attitude, your act of will.
OK.
I think that's it.
I think I've done it.
So I can only hope.
My words have been of some assistance that by your severe practice of goodwill and concern, you will be liberated from all sufferings sooner rather than later.